ل رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم ثانك يو
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
كتين الوجيز في باب سنن الوضوء so
transition into the chapter regarding
the encouraged
matter in
those things which are encouraged those
things which
the
which add to the value of the
‏knowledge in
andances
is not just about something being
accepted or rejected.
‏Very nuanced with respect to how it is
accepted, how it is received.
And the key to Allah's love
is preferred matters.
The key to Allah's
overall pleasure is fulfilling what has
been oigated upon you.
‏by
to be loved by
found in the details.
Found in the details. Let me ask you a
question. If you went and bought a brand
new car,
beautiful brand new car, paid your hard
earn money for it, and it came and it
had a big old scratch down the side.
‏Would you be all right with that? You
say, ", you know, still has four
wheels. Still going to get me where I
need to go. Of course not.
‏You would insist on the details and
that is what separates the men from the
lions. It is theail
and so the
is not a chapter
in the books of that we should ever
ignore.
‏Sometimes we see almost
attitude almost of is it w
you he a command of the propet
command or the prophet prohibition and
the question is do I have to do this
do I have to leave this alone because if
it's only must or only makr not a big
deal no has commanded that which
‏makeat
willnell
and
tellsيره
حديث القدسيز
سبحانه وتعالى
ولا يزال
عبدي يتقرب الي بالنوافل حتى احبه
[Silence]
come
to love the love isail
غسل الكفين ثلاثا في اول الوضوء
was
before
we say
‏because
of howران
اذا قمتم الى الصلاه فاغسل وجوهكم
وضو
لما ثبت عن عثمان في حكايته لوضوء النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم انه غسل كفيه ثلاثاid
عثمان
من حديث
مولى عثمان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بخاري مسلم يقول الثالث الجمع بين المضمضه
والاستنشاق ثلاثا بغرفه
handware
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
number which is common would
‏hand
in the half in the he would
move it around in his mouth spit it out
and he would blow his with his left hand
would do this twice or three times or at
least once
another way that he would make occasion
is he would do the mouth and together
three times from the same hand
of so one hand
‏of taking
[Silence]
عبد الله بن زيد رضي الله عنه في تعليمه
لوضوء رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم انه
تمضم واستنشق من كف واحده ففعل ذلك
ثلاثاكت
باي الامام مسلم يقول الرابع
المبالغه فيهما لغير الصائم فيهما يعني في
المضمضه والاستنشاق
‏in
a person is not fast as a person is not
fting the is to deepin the mouth deep
meaning all the way to the back deep
rinse the mouth and deeply rinse the nos
so to take the water into
‏take as possible into the
and into the mouth and as thly as
possible to clean out the mouth and
for the
as person is not fing
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وبالغ في الاستنشاق الا ان تكون صائما
تقديم اليمنى على اليسرى سنه الوضو
و
[Silence]
وجايف يقول لحديث عائشه رضي الله عنها
قالت كان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يحب التيامن في تنعله وترجله وطهوره وفي
شانه كله والحديث متفق عليه التيامن يعني
البدء باليمين في تنعله في لبس النعل
وترجله يعني مشط الشعر وطهوره يعني في
جميع ما يكون فيه من غسل للاعضاء او الغسل
وفي شانه كله عائشه
الله صلى الله عليه
‏and wheningir
and when wasing himself would always
wither
to all affairs allى
وجوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما
علمنا وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
شيخ السلام
عليكم السلام عليكم السلام عليكم وعليكم
السلام
نجم
اوكي